Сергій: Я впевнений у тому, що за
такою системою освіти – майбутнє.
Що це перший крок.
Якщо в тебе класний вчитель, який
може цікаво розповісти ту чи іншу тему,
то в тебе може зберегтися
зацікавленість, а зацікавленість це те,
що рухає твоє навчання вперед.
Вітаю, мене звати Елла
Василівна і я запрошую вас
на урок історії для п'ятого класу.
Знайомтеся, сьогодні у нас
на уроці Сергій і Софія.
Ви готові? Пам'ятаєте, що у
вас під рукою має бути ручка,
декілька кольорових
олівців і обов'язково зошит.
Починаємо наш урок з запису у
зошиті. Число сьогоднішнього уроку.
Хтось пише посередині
листка, хтось пише за полями,
як ви звикли, але обов'язково число.
Після того тема сьогоднішнього уроку.
Але не дивлячись на те що
сьогодні на уроці буде розглянута
нова наступна тема, ми все
таки почнемо урок з повторення.
Пам'ятаєте, що на минулому
уроці ми говорили про складні,
трагічні, героїчні події
Другої світової війни.
Сьогодні прийшов час
повторити і почнемо з дат.
Давайте спробуємо зробити це разом.
Як будемо виконувати першу вправу?
Як завжди першу вправу
я допомагаю і підказую.
Ви бачити число, дату
1 вересня 1939 року.
І відразу підказка: подія,
яка відбулася у цей день –
початок Другої Світової війни.
Тобто, коли ви побачити
наступну дату, вже без підказки
ви повинні будете пригадати, а
яка подія відбулася саме в цей час?
Але вправа на цьому не
закінчується, ми потренуємося сказати
ту саму думку, але іншим способом.
Дивиться як це треба зробити.
1 вересня 1939 року
- початок Другої Світової війни.
Можна сказати розпочалася
Друга Світова війна,
а потім перебудовуємо речення.
Друга світова війна розпочалася
1 вересня 1939 року. Справитеся?
Будь ласка наступна дата.
Я пропоную цю вправу
розпочати виконувати Сергію.
Сергій: “22 червня 1941 року - це
початок нацистсько-радянської війни”.
Абсолютно блискуча
відповідь, непогано, добре.
А Соня спробує сказати речення інакше.
Соня: “Нацистська
Німеччина вчинила напад
на Радянський Союз
22 червня 1941 року”.
Дуже добра робота. У вас
так само гарно вийшло,
тепер ви працюєте подумки,
а ви тренуєтеся самі.
З чого починаємо? Називаємо
період, а потім ми кажемо речення.
У вас є підказка невеличка,
а після того ми починаємо
з події і вказуємо наступну дату.
У вас вийшло, справилися? Вийшло?
Наступна дата і тепер починає Соня.
“Травень 1945 р.
- капітуляція нацистської Німеччини”.
До речі зверніть увагу на
світлину, саме акт капітуляції
у той момент підпису документу
на цій світлині зафіксований.
Сергію,а як треба сказати?
Сергій: “А я би сказав, закінчення війни
у Європі відбулося у травні 1945 р.”
Блискуча відповідь. Так тримати.
Беріть приклад і зробіть
краще, але у нас є ще одна дата.
Хто почне? Будь ласка Сергію.
Сергій: “2 вересня 1945 р.
- це кінець Другої світової війни”.
Соня: “Тож Друга світова війна
закінчилася 2 вересня 1945 р.”
Знаєте, мені так страшенно сподобалося,
коли Соня без мого запрошення
перехопила ініціативу, і
ви, загалом, гарно пройшли
перший етап повторення.
Другий буде дещо складніше.
У нас друга вправа. Подивиться. Я
хочу представити вашій увазі плакат.
Короткий вірш.
Йде травень
крізь хвилини дні й роки,
несе нащадкам спогади свої…
Пам’ять.
І хотілося б знати, коли сьогоднішні
учні, коли сьогоднішня молодь
згадує ті перекази, які
вони чули від своїх родичів,
сподіваюся виконали домашнє завдання.
Коли вони пригадують
фільми, які дивилися.
Коли вони пригадують рядки
з віршів чи сторінки книжок.
Для них пам'ять про війну,
що це? Пам'ять про що?
Я пропоную вам виконати таку вправу.
Вона полягає в тому, що ви
повинні продовжити речення.
Пам'ять про Другу світові війну
- це пам'ять про…
Далі декілька варіантів відповіді.
Ви маєте подивитися на
запропоновані варіанти.
Вибрати, але вибрати
тільки дві найголовніші,
найважливіші для вас відповіді.
У вас є листочки.
Берете фломастер і великими
друкованими літерами
на чистих листочках
пишете варіанти відповіді.
Сергій: А у мене питання, якщо
я маю варіант, якого тут немає.
Це вітається. Абсолютно вітається,
підтримується і буде дуже цікаво.
Мені абсолютно подобається
ваша робота, знаєте чим?
Самостійність прийняття
рішення. Я сказала 2 слова.
Сергій твердо переконаний у своїй
позиції і він написав тільки одне слово.
І більше того, ви знаєте, те слово,
яке не вказано на дошці, як підказка.
З вас і почнемо.
Сергій: “Пам'ять про другу світову
війну - це пам'ять про людей.
Чому я обрав це слово?
Тому що усі слова у рядку, які
ви мені запропонували, подвиги,
втрати, перемога, надія,
родини, випробування, ветерани.
Всі ці слова пов'язані зі словом
"людина", оскільки подвиги зробили люди.
Ми втрачали людей.
Перемогу нам принесли люди.
Надію нам давали люди.
Випробування проходили люди. І ветерани
- це також люди.
І тому я вважаю, цього одного
слова буде абсолютно достатньо
для продовження речення,
яке ви нам запропонували”.
Дякую. Що скажеш Соня?
Соня: Я буду лаконічною.
Оскільки вважаю пам'ять про
Другу світову війну - це память
про втрати і надія, що
ці втрати не повторяться.
Це передавання цієї
пам'яті, це дуже важлива річ
загальнодержавного усвідомлення,
що потрібно зробити все,
щоб це не повторилося.
Я дякую, але у нас ще
один крок у повторенні.
Загалом ви знаєте, що 8, 9 травня
є така добра людська традиція
вшановувати пам'ять загиблих
героїв Другої світової війни
і приходити до музеїв, до
меморіальних пам'ятників.
Зверніть будь ласка увагу на дошку.
І ви бачите, що це
Національний історичний музей
участі України у Другій світовій війні.
Фрагмент величезного меморіалу.
Але у цьому музеї за 45
років зібрана унікальна,
єдина в Україні колекція артефактів,
присвячених Другій світовій війні.
Чого там тільки немає. Там
і зброя, і одяг, і листи.
Але найбільше там світлин. Світлин
років війни і світлин повоєнних часів.
Зверніть увагу на дошку.
Скажіть будь ласка, що
бачимо. Ми бачимо ветеранів.
Ветеранів, але форма відрізняється.
Це наша біль і наша гордість.
Наша спільна історія
і наше непорозуміння,
вояки Червоної армії і вояки
УПА. Але подивиться які рядки.
Лиш погляньте, які вони схожі
Сивочолі герої війни
Вони з нами немов на сторожі
Найдостойніші доньки й сини
Власне, кожен з вас напевно має
вдома свій домашній сімейний альбом.
Там багато різних світлин.
І я сподіваюся, що після минулого
уроку ви гортали альбом і побачили,
роздивилися світлини своїх
бабусь, дідусів, можливо, прадідуся
і напевно вам розповіли
про його героїчне минуле.
А ми з вами тренуємо ще одну навичку.
Я б сказала повторюємо, тому
що загалом, на попередніх уроках
ми з вами вже трішечки вчились
робити це. Отже наступна світлина.
Спробуємо з вами на прикладі
саме цієї світлини потренувати
оцю навичку, як
працювати з фото джерелом.
Тобто витягнути якомога більше
інформації саме з однієї світлини.
Бачите, світлина підписана, але
може бути фотографія і без підпису.
Скажіть будь ласка, отак якби
зараз, Сергій і Соня, вам сказали б
описати цю світлину, скількома
реченнями ви її описали.
Сергій: “ Три-чотири”.
Три чотири. Чи достатньо? Щоб ця
світлина максимально розповіла нам
про подію, три-чотири речення?
Сергій: “Достатньо”.
З одного боку, так, але якщо
ви дослідник і вам треба уявити
подію якусь, можливо,
трьох-чотирьох речень не достатньо.
Але справа у навичці. Є
певний алгоритм, треба 4 кроки.
Ми будемо проходити їх дуже швидко.
Просто намотуємо то собі на вус,
як правильно аналізувати світлину,
при тому, що можна працювати
з любим фото, яке у вас буде,
і яке знадобиться в
тій чи іншій ситуації.
Перше з чого ми починаємо
- запам'ятали світлину.
Що треба робити:
Уважно роздивитися і описати
світлину. Не шкодуйте часу.
Найменші подробиці. І відразу
визначте, хто зображений,
і які речі речі зображені
на фото поруч з людьми.
Що саме хотів сказати автор
найбільш виразно і чому.
Давайте потренируемся. Соня, що
автор хотів сказати і показати?
Соня: “Я переконана, що автор
хотів наголосити на з'єднанні,
на примирення ветеранів
УПА і Червоної армії”.
Бачите, додається інформація,
можна більше з'ясувати.
Що роблять, чим
займаються люди на фото?
Спеціально зроблене
фото чи випадкове фото?
І відповідно наступне питання.
Чомусь всі ваші однокласники
забувають про фотографа.
Як фотограф там опинився,
чому він сфотографував,
яка мета, а це дуже важливо.
Тому що фотограф дивиться
на світ своїм задумом,
своїми очима і про це питання
також не варто забувати.
Останнє. Якщо вам не
відома дата фото, спробуйте
за додатковими ознаками
визначити час цієї події.
Уявимо собі, що на
світлині немає підпису.
Як би ви, Сергію,
визначали? От немає підпису.
Сергій: “Сонячна погода і зелена трава.
Це говорить про те що це
пізня весна або початок літа”.
Соня, а вам?
Соня: “А я б звернула увага
на те, що світлина кольорова,
а не чорно біла, значить вона була
зроблена приблизно після 95-96 року”.
Фантастика! Які подробиці цікаві.
Три-чотири речення? Рухаємося далі.
І обов'язково ось цей крок. Інколи
учні тай дорослі люди бояться
підходити до цього кроку.
Раптом я чогось не знаю.
Не зрозуміло. Не боїмося
ставити запитання.
Не знаємо, значить, знайдемо відповідь.
Я хочу сказати, щоб ми
не говорили про революцію,
про війну, про відбудову.
Все так як ви казали, ми
завжди говоримо про людину.
Бо людина - це початок всього, а люди,
які проживають на одній території
довгий час і вважають цю територію
своєю рідною незалежно від того,
якою мовою розмовляють, незалежно
від того у що вони вірять,
і з ким вони дружать, ці
люди складають один народ.
Ще в 1942 році Павло Тичина сказав таке.
Я єсть народ, якого правди сила,
Ніким звойована ще не була,
Яка була в мене, яка чума косила,
А сила знову розцвіла,
Щоб жить ні в кого права не питаясь,
Щоб жить, я всі кайдани розірву,
Я стверджуюсь, я утверждаюсь, бо я живу.
Народи, які проживали багато
століть на території України,
вони мріяли про свою
державу, вони будували
державу, вони боролися за неї.
Втрачали і знову мріяли
і будували і боролися.
Я пропоную розгадати
історичний кросворд.
В чому буде полягати
розгадування кросворду.
Трішечки не просте, але в
тім цілком зрозуміле завдання.
Нам що треба у кінці навчального року
- повторите те,
що ми вже знаємо і
продемонструвати свої досягнення.
Так от. Ви побачите коротенькі, на
декілька секунд, фрагменти фільму,
це може бути мультик,
це може бути інтерв'ю,
це може бути навчальний
фільм, невеликий шматочок.
І повинні розпізнати, а про
яку державність йде мова?
Кросворд ми починаємо з назви Україна.
До кожної літери окреме завдання.
Як називалася держава, де
правителі називалися князями
і столиця цієї держави було місто Київ?
Сергій: “Київська Русь”.
У 882 році Олег Віщий зустрівся з
Аскольдом та підступно вбив його.
Не знав Аскольд, що не
варто довіряти Олегам
Олег зібрав усі племена і
сказав: Київ матір міст Руських.
Круто. А подивіться на цю
дату. Якщо можете запам'ятайте.
У 5 класі не обов'язково
запам'ятовувати.
1147 р. перша згадка,
літописна згадка про Україну.
Так, було записано Україна.
А ми рухаємося далі.
Кажуть у 13 сторіччі
Галицько-Волинський князь,
для того щоб краще захистити
свою землю від монголо-татарів,
провів перемовини з Папою
Римським про допомогу,
хрестовий похід проти монголів.
Запорукою їхньої дружби була
коронація Галицько-Волинського князя.
Про кого йде мова?
Символічним освяченням
взаємних зобов'язань
стало прийняття Данилом
від Папи Римського
Інокентія 4 королівської корони.
Данило Галицький. Абсолютно правильно.
А держава називалося
- Королівство Руське.
Коли нам кажуть, що українці, та
яка держава, ви її ніколи не мали,
не вмієте будувати,
нічого у вас не вийде.
Ми з вами на уроці сьогодні
спробуємо пригадати самі
і довести всьому світу
- ми гідні мати свою державу.
Рухаємося далі.
Ви чуєте звуки цього
маршу? Це марш козацький.
Як називалася держава?
Військо Запорозьке. Наступний
етап нашого державотворення.
А події вже ближче до нашого часу.
Буквально кілька
уроків тому, ми говорили
про українську революцію
початку 20 сторіччя.
І як називалася держава.
Але були в історії України
періоди, коли вона існувала
як незалежна держава.
100 років тому у протистоянні
з Росією була проголошена
суверенна держава
- Українська Народна республіка.
Перша демократична
держава у східній Європі.
Абсолютно правильно.
Українська Народна республіка.
Ми з вами пам'ятаємо,
що українська революція,
загалом, на жаль, програла.
І УНР була знищена більшовиками,
а на території встановилася
інша – радянська – державність,
але це частина нашого
державотворчого досвіду.
І маємо про це пам'ятати.
Не відмовляємося від
жодної крихти нашої історії.
30 грудня 1922 р. перший з'їзд
рад СРСР затвердив декларацію
про утворення Союзу Радянських
Соціалістичних Республік,
а також союзний договір.
Союз складався з 4 республік:
Російської, Української,
Білоруської та Закавказької.
Українська Радянська
Соціалістична Республіка.
На минулому уроці, коли ми говорили
про Другу світову війну
і згадували 1938 р.
Ще до початку Другої світової війни.
Пам’ятаєте, маленьке
Закарпаття в страшенній боротьбі
виборювало право на свою
державність і назва цієї держави?
Перед початком Другої світової
війни кордони Європи змінилися.
Цим скористалися українці з Закарпаття,
які створили і кілька місяців
боронила Карпатську Україну, як
символ прагнення великої незалежності.
У 1941 р. під час німецької
окупації українці двічі
намагалися відновити державність.
Карпатська Україна.
24 серпня 1991 р. проголошення
Акту незалежності України
і проголошення утворення
держави Україна.
А незалежна Україна
відродилася, наче птах Фенікс
і тепер вона належить тобі.
ЇЇ виборов справжній герой,
а сьогодні саме те маєш
зробити найкращою країною у світі.
Зверніть увагу - це наша історія,
це наше право на державність.
Це наша гідність.
Україна з заходу на схід,
з півночі на південь
- єдина і соборна.
Ми повертаємося до
буремних подій 1991 р.
Запишіть будь ласка у ваших зошитах
ключову дату сьогоднішнього уроку.
Зверніть увагу на екран. Верховна рада
- це найвищий орган
законодавчої влади в Україні.
Тобто Акт проголошення
незалежності України - це закон.
Я хочу показати вам документ. Ось
так він виглядає в офіційному форматі.
Ви розраховували побачити документ
з більшої кількості сторінок?
Не задумувались? А хто спробує
вгадати скільки слів в цьому документі?
Такому важливого для кожного українця.
Соня: “Менше ста”.
Соня, точно. 93 слова!
Офіційний документ. Ми бачимо
герб, назву, печатку та підпис
голови Верховної Ради.
А це чернетка, простий
учнівський зошит. Рядок за рядком.
А ось автор Акту проголошення
незалежності, Левко Лук'яненко,
борець за незалежність України.
Бачите, він у руках тримає цю
чернетку. Знаєте, він згадував.
23 серпня, в той час в Україні
як і у всьому Радянському Союзі
була дуже напружена обстановка.
Змовники вирішили здійснити
державний переворот
і повернути країну у старі часи.
Кожна республіка розмірковувала,
що їм робити далі,
і через це, звичайно, зібралась
Верховна Рада України.
Хтось говорить, що давайте буде як буде.
Скажуть в Москві
- ми виконаємо.
Дехто каже ні, давайте
виконаємо всі ці умови,
але залишимося у Радянського Союзі.
Левко Лук'яненко, представляв меншість,
зірвався з депутатського крісла
і крикнув: «Давайте
проголосуємо за Незалежність».
В залі Верховної Ради запанувала тиша.
Всі розгубилися.
І не знаємо, як би воно
було, якби не народ,
який був під Верховною Радою.
Народ тримав у руках плакати з написами
“Україна виходить з Радянського Союзу”
і пропозиція Лук'яненка була почута.
Йому на підготовку
чернетки дали 1,5 години.
Тобто до 12:00 по полудні чернетка,
попередній тексти Акту мав би бути.
Писали всі разом, але в час
вклалися, говорить Лук'яненко.
Коли принесли Акт в зал Верховної
Ради, текст надрукували - 93 слова.
Настала субота 24 серпня 1991 р.
Під стінами Верховної Ради море людей.
А у Верховній Раді засідання
і жваве обговорення.
Обговорюють багато питань.
Акт про незалежність України
на розгляд не виносять.
Не певні вони. Багато сумнівалися,
багато не підтримували.
Лише ввечері у другій половині дня
Акт проголошення незалежності
був поставлений на голосування
і 346 депутатів сказали за.
Акт проголошення
незалежності був прийнятий.
Маленький, але доленосний документ.
Депутати згадують, що
люди зірвалися з місць
і вперше в залі звучав гімн України.
Хтось не співав навмисно.
Хтось не співав, бо не знав слів.
Але ті, хто знав слова і всім
свіїм життя йшов до цього дня,
Вони співали так, що цей
гімн чула вся Україна.
Життя змінилося. Багато наступних
законів і рішень було прийнято.
Одне з них - розірвання договору про
вхід України до Радянського союзу.
Потім було рішення про створення
Збройних Сил, про грошову одиницю,
але я хочу вам нагадати,
або може познайомити вас,
ще з однією цікавою історичною подією.
Зверніть увагу на дошку.
Ви бачите Верховну Раду.
Це світлина 4 вересня 1991 р.
Багатотисячне людське
море гуде, немов вулик.
Сесійне засідання транслюється на вулицю.
Найпопулярніше гасло
- Прапор на Раду.
Що вимагають люди від депутатів?
Підняття українського прапору
як символу Незалежної України!
Тричі ставили на голосування, і
лише втретє депутати проголосували,
щоб підняти український прапор
на куполі Верховної Ради.
Український прапор це не просто символ,
це не просто емблема –
це символ нашої свободи і гідності.
А для вас завдання. Ще який
символ ви бачите на дошці?
Тризуб. Герб.
А чому я помістила це зображення?
Це монета часів Київської Русі, часів
Ярослава. Що ми чітко бачимо на ній?
Герб. Тризуб.
Чи є в Україні великий державний
герб? Ні. Ще не затверджений.
Те що ми бачимо
- це малий герб України.
Верховна Рада прийнявши
таке доленосне рішення,
хотіла порадитись із суспільством.
Це павильно, бо ми збиралися
будувати демократичну державу,
а отже треба було спитати у громадян
України, чи підтримують вони
ідею створення самостійної України.
Справа в тому, що ситуація
була в той час не проста.
Багато людей, хто народилися і жили в
Радянському Союзі,
страшенно боялись
втратити Радянський Союз.
Хтось сумнівався, що не
зможемо побудувати нову державу,
але багато людей хотіли
будувати нову незалежну Україну.
Ніхто не знав цим
закінчиться референдум.
Референдум
- це всенародне опитування.
Дуже часто референдуми проводять,
щоб порадитися з народом.
Але інколи референдуми
набувають державної ваги - як закон.
На 1 грудня 1991 р. був призначений
Всеукраїнський референдум
з одним запитанням: чи підтримуєте ви
Акт проголошення незалежності України?
92% населення підтримали Акт.
В той самий час відбувалися
вибори президента України.
Ми бачимо першого Президента України.
Подивіться дату.
Дата інавгурації і присяги
Президента України.
Зверніть увагу 1 грудня вибори, 5 грудня
- інавгурація.
Час не чекав, треба було
братися за розбудову країни.
А що це за книги біля президента?
Конституція України.
Ніхто не мав зразка, як президент
має вступати у свої повноваження.
Тому був прописаний сценарій,
де президент має присягати
на вірність українському народу на
Конституції та на духовній святині –
Пересопницькому Євангеліє. З
того часу це стало традицією.
Але є проблема. Конституції
на той час не було.
Тому Л.М. Кравчук мусив приносити
присягу на старій конституції.
А для чого державі конституція?
Для регулювання прав людей.
Правильно врегулювання відносин
між людьми та визначення
статусу та місця кожної людини.
Визначення правил
побудування молодої держави.
Як побудувати законодавчу та виконавчу
владу, як має діяти судова влада,
які стосунки мають бути між державою
(органами управління) і народом,
яким ці органи управління
будуть керувати.
Тобто, без Конституції - ніяк.
Але Конституція це не проста справа. Для
творення конституції знадобився час.
28 червня 1996 року була
прийнята Конституція України
Верховною Радою України.
Конституція - Основний Закон Держави.
Конституция не великий документ, але дуже
важливий, з ним ви познайомитесь пізніше,
а зараз я хочу звернути
увагу на статтю 1 Конституції.
Як ви гадаєте - слова дуже
складні для вас, не прості -
а мова йде про те в цій першій Статті,
якою має бути Українська Держава -
суверенна і незалежна,
"Щоб жить — ні в кого права не питаюсь. "
На попередніх уроках ми
казали - "в своїй хаті - своя правда"
Суверенна та незалежна, демократична,
соціальна, правова держава.
Демократична - все, що відбувається в
цій Державі, має відбуватися з волі народу
і за безпосередньої участі народу.
Соціальна - держава, яка буде
дбати про кожного громадянина.
Правова - держава, в якій
будуть дбати про права людини
і закон буде стояти на
сторожі прав людини.
Але є ще одна стаття
- Стаття 3.
Людина, її життя і
здоров'я, честь і гідність,
недоторканність і безпека
визнаються в Україні
найвищою соціальною цінністю.
Що є найбільшой цінністю в Україні
згідно Конституції - Основного Закону?
Людина.
Сергію ви говорили про
відносини між державою і людьми.
То які відносини визначає
Конституція між державой і людьми?
Правові.
Так, але які це відносини?
Як держава має ставитись до людини і
що людина повинна очікувати від держави?
Держава має поважати людину, її
життя та здоров'я, її честь та гідність.
Дуже часто я питаю, держава для
людини чи людина для держави?
Держава для людини!
Скажіть чи часто ви мрієте? Чи думали,
якою ви б хотіли бачити Україну?
У вас є нагода. Достаємо
чисті білі аркуші.
Беремо фломастери. І зараз
ми будемо малювати свою Мрію.
Наш урок добігає кінця.
Ваші малюнки не завершені.
Ваше домашнє завдання –
намалювати «Україну Майбутнього».
Сьогодні Елла Василівна
справила чудове враження,
впевнений що з таким вчителем
дітям буде цікаво вчитися.
Насправді для мене як
для учениці, кожен предмет
сприймається через призму вчителя,
і на жаль не можна зробити так,
щоб кожному підходив якийсь вчитель,
бо деякі вчителі більш харизматичні,
тому, якщо є така альтернатива
і є нагода подивитися на той самий
предмет іншими очима, чому би ні,
тим паче ця школа зібрала
найкращих з усієї України.